hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the key concepts running
throughout really
all of gabriel marcel's work and playing
a significant role in concrete
approaches to investigating
the ontological mystery is a term
that we translate as availability and
you know that could be a little bit
misleading
think about what are your availabilities
for having this conference call
it's not quite the same thing as that
it's a broader conception
and it's a translation of the french
term disponability
uh to be at the disposal of somebody and
hence to be available
and it comes up in a context within this
particular essay where marcel
is framing the traditional christian
virtues of faith hope
and charity in terms of his own
his own philosophy and what's
corresponding to charity
is is availability and this is connected
to
as he says being as presence
being present to another
and so he he brings this up without
mentioning availability at the
the very beginning by talking about some
some other terms being
given as presence and so he says that
um here we go
[Music]
we have to we have to examine this
neutral and ambiguous term presence
and replace it perhaps with influx and
he goes on and he says it's only on the
level of the meta-problematical that the
the
notion of influx can be appropriately
understood
if influx were taken in an objective
sense like a physical force
we would be no longer in metaphysics but
physics and then this would give rise to
all sorts of objections
but then he goes on he says when i say
that a being is given to me as a
presence or as a being which amounts to
the same thing for the other is only a
being for me
if he or she is a presence this means
i cannot treat the other as if he or she
were simply placed there
positioned in front of me it's not a
merely spatial
relationship between two totally
independent separate
things he goes on and he says
there arises between the other and me a
relationship
which in a certain sense goes way beyond
the conscious awareness
i may have of it and he he uses other
other ways of of arranging this in terms
of prepositions or our understanding
of spatial relationships here he says
the other is not only before me the
other is also
within me now what does that mean does
that mean that the other somehow
penetrates me you know with their aura
or presence or something like that well
yes in a certain sense i
make room for themselves
within the complex thing that is my
being and he goes on and he says
more exactly the physical categories are
transcended they're no longer accurate
or illuminating the word influx
expresses though into spatial fashion
the kind of
notice the term uses here enrichment
from within
that happens the moment presence occurs
now this could be other human beings
this could be
reading an author and learning about
them through their book this could
happen through the experience of music
something that marcel was
very attuned to this could happen also
with animals or with the
environment but there's something more
there's a richness that's being
provided that means that i am in some
way
taking something else within me
and he goes on and he says here we go
even when i can neither touch you nor
see you i feel it
you are with me it would be a betrayal
of you not to be
assured of this and then he says with me
let us notice here the metaphysical
character of this word
with which is so rarely been
acknowledged by philosophers
and which corresponds neither to a
relation of
inherence nor of imminence
nor a relation of exteriority
it will be of the very essence and then
he says and here i must use the latin
word of a genuine
co essa s says the word for being
co together a being with a being
together
that doesn't amount to simply and you
know
a confusion or a uh
effacement of the differences between
the the others in this recognizes that
there is a distinction
but which makes room in the self
for somebody else to to be there is this
the same thing as when we say i'm giving
somebody
uh space rent free in my head
internalizing their voices for example
or their values
it can be connected with that right that
can be part of what he's talking about
his availability but that's not the only
way and there may be times where we
don't where we need to expel
them from from our head as well
not only so that you know it's good for
us but also so we can be
with others as well and so
there's a kind of intimacy that he he
talks about
here um a real intimacy susceptible to
this
kind of decomposition that a critical
reflection subjects it to
but we know already there exists another
kind of reflection that reflects on this
one right so if this is a
possibility for us not just when we're
experiencing things or being with other
people
but even when we're doing philosophy we
can be
with marcel as we're going through this
essay we can make room for him
and he goes on
and he tells us that we're preparing to
move
into another realm here and he says
the value of such an intimacy will be
that much greater and incontestable
as the relationship situates itself more
clearly in a world
of complete spiritual availability that
is to say of pure charity
and i observe in passing that the
ascending dialectic of creative fidelity
corresponds to the ascending dialectic
of hope so
he's talking about something here that
goes beyond just the individual
connected with another individual he's
not just talking about
one's own capacity
for availability he's talking about a
world
and the degree of complete spiritual
availability or
charity within it what is this word
charity another way of translating this
is love in traditional
christian theology in addition to the
cardinal virtues
that were recognized by ancient
philosophers of justice wisdom fortitude
and temperance there were also
distinguished these these three virtues
they're not the only ones of course
talked about but faith hope and charity
and charity we often think of as well
i'm going to give something to those who
are less fortunate than myself
that is an act of charity that is not
the totality of charity charity means
love karitas is a form of love towards
the other the translation
in greek of this that some people may
know is agape
this self-giving capacity
for benefiting others
not just benefiting them by checking off
a box or
handing them some money but
genuinely being engaged with them so
he talks about experiences that we have
of availability
and in availability
and this is this is quite interesting
here he says it's an undeniable fact of
experience
but one that's difficult to translate
intelligibly that there are certain
beings who reveal themselves to us
as present what does that mean he gives
examples here
who are available when we are suffering
when we need someone in whom to confide
and there are others
by contrast who
don't give us that feeling despite
whatever may be their good will
and here he's making some important
distinctions right
so there's experiences that we have of
those who are present
for us available for us and those who
are not
it's not the same thing as good will a
person can have good will
and at the same time be unavailable in
this respect
so they i wish you the best you know
sincerely blah blah blah and
send you on your way right
it's also not the same thing as
attentiveness as he points out
he goes on and he says we must note
right away that the distinction between
presence and non-presence cannot be
reduced
to the opposition between the fact of
being attentive and that of being
distracted
the most conscientious attentive
listener can give me the
impression of being unavailable he or
she brings me nothing
they cannot really create a space for me
in his or her life no matter what
material services he or she may lavish
on me and then he says in reality
there's a way of listening that is a
giving of oneself there's another way of
listening that
is a refusal a refusal to give
of one's self a material gift or a
visible action
is not necessarily a sign
of presence presence is what
availability is presence to the other
making room
within yourself within your life for
that person
and and what's what's on their mind what
their needs are
perhaps inarticulate not well thought
out needs
you might have to listen to some other
nonsense and bs
before they can actually reveal to you
what their real
issue that they're struggling with is
and so that's
availability right being attentive being
a good listener
nodding saying so what i hear you saying
etc etc etc
is that's not necessarily the same thing
as availability
it's whether you give yourself to the
other or not
and giving yourself doesn't mean talking
about all your own stuff
and framing it just in your own ways it
also means
a sort of receptivity as well giving and
and not taking but giving and getting
giving and accepting giving and even
welcoming
go hand in hand here in availability
so you know he goes on and says this is
a really great way of
framing it the being who is available is
the one who is capable of being totally
with me when i need
him or her by contrast
the being who is unavailable is the one
who seems to extend a temporary loan
from among the considerable resources
that are at his or her
disposal for the first i am a presence
for the second
i am an object an object that's that's a
person object but an object that gets a
certain amount of time
and a certain amount of listening and a
certain amount of response and then
that's
it i'll make you alone and it may be a
generous
good-hearted loan from within but i'm
only going to go so far and then after
that my ears are closed after that my
time is up
after that i really have no uh more to
do with you you're on your own jack as
we might say
because i've helped you out enough so
it's it's quite
i mean there's many ways of being
unavailable that just amount to being a
jerk
and ignoring people from the start or
being totally obsessed with oneself and
distracted we're going to talk about
that in a moment
but there's also ways of being
unavailable even when somebody
uses the language of availability or
attentiveness or care or concern
but isn't really committed this is an
existential
position here a commitment of
oneself and interestingly here's another
thing to point out as we're going to
look at in just a moment
sometimes when people aren't able to be
available for others
we can we can you know blame them for it
but it stems from how damaged they are
how much they are turned in on
themselves
and so you know should we say well
they're totally blameless in that
yes in a certain respect they may not be
actually responsible for that or if they
are it's because of a whole bunch of
choices they made along the way to close
themselves off at different points that
then produce these
effects later on that they had no idea
they were they're careening towards
but it's a bad state it's not a good
state and so
we can we can distinguish between
blaming somebody for something being
their responsibility and blaming
somebody for being
a mess being in the condition that they
are
and and it's more of a it's really
unfortunate that this is the case for
you and we might have to be available
for them
as well as as a result in order to help
them get out of that if they're going to
get out of it
and so he's got a number of interesting
analyses
um that he provides here the first of
which is this notion of
being totally with the other versus a
temporary loan
he then also talks about um at the heart
of unavailability
we find there's always a certain
alienation and he gives some examples he
says
others invite my sympathy for a certain
misfortune they tell me about
i understand what they describe i
recognize
in the abstract the people they're
talking about to serve my compassion
i know it would be logical and just to
respond to this case with sympathy
which sympathy i confer if you will but
only in thought
because i finally have to admit i'm not
moved it doesn't doesn't affect me
besides i regret this contradiction i i
say that i should in fact be
moved by this but i'm not moved i don't
care
it's not my problem one could say that's
that's the
actually a lot of people will say it's
not my problem a lot of other people say
that's not in my job description
right and they'll often be talking
outside of the workplace
about other things that we could call
functions in a marcelian way
he says what remains with me is the
enemies inadmissible feeling that after
all these these are people i don't know
and if one had to be touched by every
human misfortune life would no longer be
possible
so that's you know one
aspect alienation is a term that he's
using here this is a very pregnant term
we can think about all the different
ways in which people can be alienated
from themselves
from others from you know the essence of
human being
you know from their their labor from
all sorts of matters from their their
history their past
and these alienations are ways
of you might say causing fissures breaks
within a person that make it more
difficult for them to be
available to others and he goes on and
he says you know in the normal
development of a human being
there is an increasingly precise and
almost automatic sorting out of what is
one concern
what is not what one is responsible for
and what one is not and then he goes on
and gives this metaphor of like
concentric
circles of concern or lack of concern
we become the center of a kind of mental
space that is arranged in concentric
zones
of decreasing interest and involvement
he talks about us secreting
a hard shell right
that becomes increasingly hard and
imprisons us
then he says we can have encounters that
break through this
it could be an other who enters my life
and i recognize the need and i become
available to them i break out of that
shell or it could be the sanctity
realized in certain beings
that reveals to us what we call the
normal order
is from a higher point of view merely
the subversion of an order which is its
opposite when we
reflect on what people call the
transcendent or the holy
and not in an abstract way but in a
genuine
concrete way that can change the world
for us and we can see
wow this person over here who i
previously passed up every time that i
was engaged with them
not really engaged but doing something
with them in the past
they are in some respect a
reflection of something that i ought to
value i ought to like open myself up to
them and find out what's actually there
what's going on makes make room in
myself
overcome their initial suspicion be
since i've treated them in this way
in the past he also says something
really
interesting about unavailability and
egoism or selfishness
he says to be unavailable is not only
preoccup not only to be
preoccupied with oneself but in a
certain way
encumbered with oneself to be entangled
with oneself this is different
than just focusing on oneself this is
not being able to get away
from focusing on oneself the things that
you have used to
define who you are could be you know
your status symbols
your wealth your relationships with
others
and he goes on and he's got some really
interesting cautions here
he says that the immediate object can
vary in an indefinite number of ways to
be preoccupied with oneself
can mean to be caught up in one's
health one's wealth one's romantic
life and even notice this one
even with one's own interior perfection
people who are engaging in personal
development
can become preoccupied with themselves
and
encumbered by themselves in that way am
i making it to the next stage
am i doing things that are holding
myself back and in doing so they
they lose sight of other other human
beings they lose sight
of all the things towards which we ought
to have availability
or disposability to be disposed towards
and he goes on and he says what must be
recognized is that the opposite of the
being preoccupied with himself or
herself
is not the being who is empty or
indifferent
the opposition is between the being who
is transparent and the one who is opaque
and we have to try to figure this out
it's a question of a sort of block or
fixation and he suggests that perhaps a
certain kind of
psychotherapy or psychoanalysis might be
useful for figuring
this sort of thing out and he says what
is remarkable is that this anxiety
persists at the center of the fixation
and gives it this constricted
character that i spoke of in connection
with the degradation
of the will and he talks about people
who are
engaging in pessimism or despair as
as often preoccupied with the self as
well
by contrast what is the available soul
like
he says the soul who is most at the
disposal of
others is the most consecrated the most
inwardly dedicated to genuinely know
yourself and to be a self
means to be available which means
opening yourself
up to others not just shrinking yourself
inward
keeping them at a distance not allowing
them to distract you from your spiritual
quest
you might say that you know the the
emblem of this
is the good samaritan who picks up the
the person who's been attacked
uh on the road somebody who's actually
his his enemy
who he doesn't have to stop for and uh
you know takes some time out of his day
takes him to the
local inn dresses his wounds and says
here's some money take care of this guy
i'm gonna be back and i'm gonna check in
that i'm going to be back and i'm going
to be check in as a central part of the
story
marcel's not talking about that story
here of course but i think that that
narrative is very
helpful it's a continual thing there's
it's not just a loan
of well i'll be there for you right now
because you're you know your mom died
and i'll be a shoulder for you to cry on
for oh about the next six hours
and then i'm getting on the plane and
i'm flying back to where
i live and then you know maybe we'll
have a few facebook exchanges
or some emails or you know a skype call
but
you get six hours after that and that's
it
that's that's not a way of being
available right
it's it's you never know when you're
going to be called upon
again but marcel is saying that this is
the the path
to really being a full self
the one who is at the most at the
disposal of others is the one who
is the most consecrated in line with you
know whatever is transcendent
and the most inwardly dedicated this
soul he says
is protected against despair because
this soul knows it does not belong
just to itself and that the only
legitimate use it can make of its
freedom
consists in recognizing that fact
so this is you might say and he
recognizes this
put out as kind of an ideal whether or
not we are available to others
is not an on off switch either we were
you know previously not available and
now we are
it is on a continuum but we should
strive
according to marcel as much as possible
to
be available that is what it means
to be genuinely ethical to be committed
within the world this is a possibility
for human beings
some things stand in the way and those
would be obstacles
to this this disposition
of availability
you